[Music]
hello everybody thanks for letting me be
here I'm really really excited to be
here so I heard that there was a
robotics program that was launched today
and I've been studying robotics for
probably over half of my life so I
thought I'd share a little bit of a
passion of why I've been not giving up
on robotics and I'll probably keep going
for a long long way so the title is Robo
robots with that belly button hopefully
you get to go through a little bit of a
journey I'm a little bit of an unusual
roboticist I didn't start out on the
right way which maybe many of you have
and many of the young kids are now doing
which is through FIRST Robotics
tinkering with electronics learning to
code I did none of that I really started
out playing tennis and this is all I
wanted to do all my life that's it
turns out when you bet on one thing
sometimes it doesn't work out but I got
injured so much in college at some point
I have to think of something else to do
luckily I loved math and physics so I
banked on it said okay brainstorm tennis
math physics what can I do what I came
up with was this I came up with the idea
of building a robotic tennis buddy for
myself great idea I could build great
legs that can run around on a tennis
court the other side and has head and
the holds a tennis racket smart enough
to know too how to play tennis with me
on the day that I want to play really
well
it was stimulating me on the day I'm
just you know depressed
it would make sure that I win but you
know what it turns out to be this
journeys really long and when I went
from undergraduate robotics lab where
Professor didn't discourage me from
going and doing this and imagining in my
head one day I'll build a robot like
that something that will continue to
help me not be on tennis not but not
just tennis but beyond that so I wasn't
even grabbed school and build this thing
this is now I was at Berkeley and then I
went to
he and I helped build this robot named
cog it still has a belly button if you
look really carefully I was a building
and aiming to build a robot with a belly
button because that's all I knew
I knew that robot was supposed to look
like us because Jetsons and Robocop and
Star Wars taught me so but you know what
as I started building this when I start
to get more and more curious about how
human brain works and what it really
mean to do robotics and I wanted to
apply myself differently I start to
think robotics a little bit differently
and come to this picture I just take the
class of robotics you might not be
building a humanoid robot you might not
be learning how to build a precise
little details of fingers or legs but
you will definitely be learning that
you'll be learning how to sense the
world and then use that information to
think really carefully and I heard a
little questions relate to machine
learning earlier and of course then
outcome we have to take action whether
with the motors or some other way to
take actions into the world and then let
it be and then again sense what had
happened in that feedback loop that's
what makes robots robot and you know if
you encapsulate that in a mechanical
system then it doesn't necessarily have
to have a belly button or legs or arms
or eyes so that's how I view robotics
and that's how I have been really
utilizing some of the expertise that
I've learned in robotics in two
different ways so here's something that
you would definitely not say it's
robotics well with my definition this is
one of the simplest version of robotics
so it's a light switch on the top
there's an occupancy sensor attached to
it this occupancy sensor knows when you
come into the room you know those
conference rooms you walk in and the
light turns on and that person's okay
you don't think it's magical but it
turns out to be pretty hard so you have
also experienced a failure case where
you're sitting and typing away and the
light turns off and you're like crap
what's happening so you know it's
thinking and in deciding making
decisions about when
turn off the light to be good about
saving energy and also not be annoying
right now it start to get more complex
more than you might imagine from
something on the wall but that's the
simplest pipe I would call robotics now
you can go to the extreme that's where
I've been throughout the graduate school
journey and then when I was a professor
at Carnegie Mellon in the University of
Washington I just wanted to go in a
rabbit hole as deep as possible in
robotics so I built this robotic device
and specifically wanted to build a human
body part that made human human hand
well bellybutton well maybe doesn't make
human human anyway so the hand is
amazing right so somehow we were able to
build the society because of the thing
that we got so wanted to understand why
it's so amazing can we build it can we
replicate in robotics if you see how
robotic hands are now it's very
disappointing still it can barely carry
and grab objects in and manipulate move
things around and if you just spin like
something in your hand
that's a journal paper right there right
so so I built that spending years
figuring out how the bones should be
putting 30 motors in the forearm
squeezing them in pushing the technology
of motors to take you know pushing the
technology in terms of sensors sensing
from the skin sensing from the pool the
muscles have sensors too and then using
all this information to do this complex
motion now on top of it I wanted that to
be controlled by human brain signals so
working with people with neurological
disorders having them or people who had
went that arm would they had amputation
having their brain think about moving
the arm they can no longer move I wanted
this robot to move so getting from
different kind of sensor mechanisms in
the people's brain or on the surface and
then taking the electrical signals
interpreting that sending them into the
30 different motor signals and then
having fingers move and that's where my
research was and then this is also
really exciting and I'm sure because of
all the things that we've done and all
the graduate students that we've studied
with there are things that
made profound difference for the future
of people's life and that's exciting but
wanted to you know so this throughout
the spectrum of things one of the things
that really caught me and then I
continue to have it as my theme and I
want you to think about it as you think
about robotics program to if this
sharing of robots and humans doing some
tasks together ultimately I mean it's
even from the beginning when I wanted to
build this tennis robot I wanted to
build it to help me human and really
robots are about how can we enhance
humans to be able to do more or you know
think that they lost how to do so in
this case is the prosthetic hand tying
shoe now here's an interesting problem
should this hand have full machine
learning and the brain signal simply say
hi shoe and then just okay I know
exactly how to do everything and just go
ahead and I'd recognize a shoe do you
recognize a shoe string move all the
drinks you know angles and then do it
the brain didn't do much or should the
brain do everything as we do it right we
tie shoes with commanding all muscles
individually to move individual fingers
to tie shoe which one should we choose
to do as we move forward in the world
where robots are in our society working
together I don't have an answer for it
and turns out it depends on who the user
is we've learned it in different ways
even from nest products that we ship
that what people ask for is different
some people who are missing arm wanted
to do everything on their own even if it
took two years to learn it they wanted
to learn it themselves some said you
know what I'm pleased we please just do
it from you that technology so advanced
Kuwait so you know I think that the
thing that I keep thinking about as I
work for a company like nest nest has a
mission to really create a home that
takes care of people inside it and the
world around it and that really hits me
I'm building robots to help people and
ok we built these robots from that for
those of you who don't know about messed
too much I'll give you a quick example
of a thermostat
so the thermos that we build most of the
thermoset out there are things like you
go in the room and then you move out you
know leaver or turn it and then the room
temperature goes up you leave the house
and then you forgot to turn it off while
you're wasting energy
so next layer technology came and then
said okay programmable thermostat so we
program it and then know ahead of time
when you're going to go out of out of
the house we'll turn it down well it
turns out you don't necessarily have a
very predictable life everyday so we
came up with a thermostat which is not
just loaded with you know with the
temperature sensor but occupancy sensor
light sensors and all kinds of sensors
jam-packed in there knowing what status
you might you know what status your
house is in what kind of things you
might be doing and making sure that we
understand and partner with you how much
energy you want to save because you
touch it when you want certain things to
change and then listen and then make
actions in terms of what temperature to
make the house it seems kind of simple
but turns out it's really a geek inside
and I used to say I'm a geek inside
sitting in there and making sure that
you're comfortable and also at the same
time saving energy so we've found that
and it kept innovating in people's homes
through all kinds of different products
and throughout this some of the things
that's falling out that I love is that
we're starting to help people so using
those robotics technology and homes this
is a guy named Eric hey how he was I
work he has nest products in his house
and one day he receives a notification
one of the devices that we built took
action to let him know that there was a
stranger or some movement that it
doesn't usually see happening at his
front door when he's at work turns out
what he saw was his dad who's a little
bit has a dementia roaming around not
knowing what to do so
Derek was he able to immediately take an
action call neighbor and said my dad is
at the door can you actually help and
then was able to get grandpa in the
right spot and he would just give us
able to get home correctly and thought
wow it's so great the device
that we build that sense thought about
it took action was able to help someone
same thing here this family had also
messed products
thermostats and smoke detectors CO
detectors carbon monoxide detectors will
happen for this family was that again
they were there outside of the house and
then and during the time the during the
day they get a notification saying that
their carbon monoxide level is getting
high but not only that our smoke
detector talked to our thermostat and
said hey dude over there
maybe you look connected to furnace you
might be producing carbon monoxide so
can you turn it off so by the time they
were even home those things were taken
care of and I think those kind of things
that we can start to imagine doing in a
house because we're sensing because
we're thinking we're taking actions
that's what the core robotics is even
without the belly button so this is of
course where we want to get to right
like we want to live in the house where
there's a robot that you can order
around and they you don't have to cook
anything in have to clean dishes and you
don't have to do any of that but you
know I'm still okay myself building a
robot or even maybe living in it for the
time being so I do go through robotics
program and think about whenever you
hear the robotics try not to necessarily
think about that thing with the belly
buttons and those people don't think of
something like this in your head and
then we're going to be on the same page
and we're going to be starting to really
help a lot of people thank you very much
you